d'accord
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu dois comprendre
[Applaudissements]
logique
tu dois essayer d'ignorer alors cela signifie
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
que tu dois faire c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup d'amis  qui se nourrissent
mais quelles que soient les raisons pour lesquelles tu le fais pour
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais des émotions de seconde main
[Musique] [
Musique]
merci [
J'ai réfléchi à leur nouvelle
direction
mais je dois dire que
j'ai  Je pensais que
ça me faisait peur de ressentir ça
Qu'est-ce que l'amour a à voir
avec
ce qu'est l'amour mais une émotion de seconde main
]
Je dois le faire
mais une seconde de plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci [
Applaudissements]
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]